hi guys scifi recapped here
before we start warning
spoilers ahead today i'm going to
explain a 2011 science fiction and
action movie called bombat robo
the movie begins with a talented
scientist named dr vasey grinner dr vasi
who is developing an android humanoid
robot with his assistants
he works so hard on the project until he
ignores hundreds of calls from his
girlfriend sana after working all day
and all night the robot development is
finally finished and dr vasey gives the
final touches on it
the robot is able to perform simple
human movements such as standing and
walking
afterwards he transfers all necessary
data to the robot including language
arts and much more making the robot
possess the same behavior as normal
human beings
fed up with his boyfriend not calling
her back sana angrily goes to vasey's
laboratory but the scientist refuses to
meet her
she then walks away in tears
the assistants give the robot speech
training but the doctor finds out that
they have been teaching him abusive
phrases which makes him angry and warns
them to make it even more realistic dr
vasey envelops the robot with human-like
skin and clothes
finally the scientist returns home and
introduces his creation to his parents
while having lunch together the mother
decides to name the robot chitty she
then orders the robot to put the tv on
but it throws the tv away and breaks it
dr vasey realizes that his creation
still lacks logical thinking skill
he trains chitty how to drive in a
crowded road where it accidentally
crashes his expensive mercedes
they eventually arrive safely at a
barber shop where chitty rapidly scans
all the magazines and demands more books
as he has finished reading it all
the barber even gives him a phone book
but it is still too easy for him
he manages to reveal the phone number
and the name of other customers
a few moments later dr vasey approaches
sana and apologizes to her but the woman
wants to end the relationship because
she thinks his boyfriend would choose
machines over her
she then returns all the boring stuff
and books dr vasey gave her while
complaining about him never being
romantic
vasey demands the woman to return the
512 kisses that he has given
sana has no choice but to kiss him to
return the favor and they end up
reconciling
meanwhile shitty is confronted by a
police officer and he argues with him
but his statement just makes the officer
confused as it claims that it has no
parents and lives in an ip address
the officer asks chidi for some money
because he broke the law but he cuts his
hand instead
not long after dr vasey and his
girlfriend show up and they drive away
some time later dr vasey introduces
chitty in an international conference
chitty shows off his capabilities and
skills in front of the audiences
it even manages to answer all their
answers effortlessly which amazes the
audiences
after the presentation dr vasey's former
mentor dr bora comes to him and he seems
unhappy with vasey's breakthrough
creation he brings chitty for a walk
while secretly asking the robot several
questions focusing on its specifications
but it refuses to answer and tells vasey
about that
he politely says that he is unwilling to
spoil anything until he gets a patent
turns out that borah is also developing
android humanoid robots but they are not
following orders and cannot function
properly which causes him to envy vasey
one of the robots even attempts to
strangle him after being scolded
sarah takes chitty with her to assist
her in the upcoming exam
however they are disturbed by loud
noises from the neighborhood the pair
warned them to lower the volume but the
boys keep increasing the volume and
challenge them instead
chidi uses his infrared power to give
them a lesson by destroying the music
player
sana continues studying but suddenly a
loud music from the local festival
emerges
shitty tries to negotiate but they don't
care so it goes inside and simply breaks
the music player the men are furious and
attempt to attack chitty but shitty
activates electromagnetic mode which
pulls all their weapons and every metal
stuff towards it
shitty even humiliates one of the men
who still tries to attack
the pair then walks away while being
praised by the local people
the next day shitty gives sana a spy
earphone to provide her with the exam
answers
two professors approach chitty and ask
what the robot is doing
chitty innocently reveals that he is
helping sana in the exam
they confront sana in the exam room but
sana throws the transmitter away and
admits she doesn't know chitty at all
the robot is confused with the current
situation as he is programmed to never
lie
the professors eventually believe her
and kick the robot out of the college
sana is now clueless in the exam but
shitty somehow sneaks into the ceiling
and provides her all the answers on the
paper
on the train the gangsters from the
festival confront the pair this time
they are equipped with non-metal weapons
the fight ensues but chitty manages to
eliminate each of them effortlessly
unfortunately shitty eventually runs out
of the battery and gets kicked out of
the train
the gangsters harass sauna who screams
for help
chidi hears this and charges himself
with a cable from an electric box
chitty returns to the train and
ruthlessly beats everyone up with
chinese martial arts
they arrive home safely and dr vasey
repairs the damage on chitty as time
goes by shitty now also becomes a
servant and does a lot of housework
while also being trained for military
purposes at the same time
at some point dr vasey brings chitty to
artificial intelligence research and
development or art headquarters for
evaluation
the scientist states that android
humanoids like chitty can be used in
wars to minimize casualties then asks r
to give him approval to mass produce the
robot
the board members test chitty several
logical thinking questions and it
answers all of them flawlessly the
others are about to give the approval
until borah suddenly intervenes and
orders chidi a lot of exhausting
commands
shitty performs all the commands
effortlessly until borah orders it to
kill vasey
the robot rushes to his creator but
borah commands him to stop just before
it stabs vasey
however vasey gets stabbed a little bit
causing borah to disapprove the request
he states that chitty is not ready for
military use and only can be utilized
for daily routine work
the disappointed vasey and chitty drive
home when they come across a huge fire
accident
shitty immediately runs towards the
burning flat and rescues the trapped
people not caring about his skin and
clothes getting burned out the hero runs
back and forth to rescue the remaining
trapped people until chitty brings a
woman who was taking a bath out of the
burning flat
unfortunately the woman feels humiliated
as everyone witnesses her naked
she runs into the street in tears and
gets hit by a truck
borah who is watching everything from
his room immediately calls dr vasey and
blames his robot for killing a woman
because the video of the woman goes
viral borah on behalf of the ministry of
defence orders vasi to stop the project
the scientist states that he can add
human emotions into chitty so borah
gives him a month to improve the robot
dr vasey immediately feeds the robot a
lot of lessons about human emotions and
he installs hormone software into it the
training continues until chitty is
struck by lightning which causes it to
malfunction
the next day shitty is fully repaired
but dr vasey is fed up with the fact
that the robot is not making any
progress and yells at it shitty
surprisingly shouts back showing that he
now has emotions it now feels sadness
and even pays a visit to the woman's
grave which makes dr vasey extremely
happy
soon after sana is informed about a
woman who is having labor problems and
the trio rushed to the hospital
shitty offers to help but the doctor
doesn't allow it
they both argue until the doctor is
convinced with chitty's capabilities
the robot leads the operation while
streaming the procedure online so others
can watch his skill and kindness
the baby is eventually born in a healthy
condition and everyone is celebrating
borah arrives at the hospital and has no
choice but to approve chitty
he warns the scientist that sana could
ditch him and choose chitty as the robot
now has emotions
that evening shitty repeatedly rewinds
the moment when sonic kissed him
on the other side borah secretly
arranges a meeting with a terrorist who
wants to take advantage of the humanoid
robot's capabilities to cause chaos
the terrorist orders 100 robots and
gives him the down payment however few
months later the terrorist almost shoots
him in the head since his ordered robots
haven't finished yet
the scene moves back to dr vasey and
chitty who buy jewelry for sana as that
day is her birthday
chitty follows everything vasey does and
he now even dares to disobey his creator
at the party sana is more impressed with
chitty's gift and decides to wear it
leaving vasey and jealousy
he gets insecure and randomly announces
to everyone that he is going to marry
her everyone celebrates the announcement
and the jealous chitty reacts by asking
her to dance which she agrees to
at some point shitty almost kisses sana
but vasey intervenes
they go outside where chitty admits that
he loves sanna too
this statement enrages its creator but
chitty refuses to obey any longer
however sana makes it clear that humans
and machines cannot be together
she also adds that she loves the
scientist which makes the robot
devastated and walks away
later that night borah approaches chitty
and provokes the robot to join him
claiming that he knows its worth and
will give an equal treatment to chitti
the next day chitty undertakes the
military evaluation to determine whether
the robot is fit in the army
however when being asked to throw a
grenade the robot turns the grenade into
a grenade rose and mentions sana
chitty even starts reciting romantic
poetry while imagining sana everyone
laughs at chitty and walks away
dr vasey can't hold it anymore thus he
angrily breaks the robot apart while
stating his disappointment towards the
robot
shitty insists that he didn't make any
mistakes and only want sana
vasey eventually puts an end to the
robot's life and throws his spare part
away
the couple then have fun and vasey
officially proposes to sana
meanwhile borah drives to the landfill
to retrieve chitty's junk
he then brings the robot to his own
laboratory where chitty repeatedly says
that he loves sana
the robot eventually agrees to give the
information needed to borah after he
offers to restore the robot into his
original form
while fixing the robot borah installs a
red destructive chip into chitty which
turns the robot into a demon
chitty awakens and is satisfied with his
new look the robot is informed that sana
and vasey are getting married that day
so chitty immediately rushes into the
wedding hall where chitty attempts to
take sana with her while throwing the
scientist away
shitty becomes out of control and the
robot even shoots several innocent men
while heading out of the hall
the police chase after him but shitty
uses his telekinesis power to take down
their motorcycles easily
even though chitty is outnumbered he
still manages to dominate the police
with his enormous strength
the pursuit continues until the police
block the road and continuously shoot
chitty
however the robot uses the mercedes as a
shield
after cornered shitty activates
electromagnetic mode and pulls all
rifles towards him
shitty launches a counter attack and
slaughters everyone on site
the police confront vasey and blame him
for the damage caused by the robot he
calls chitty and concludes that its
system has been corrupted thus he
commands chitty to return to his lab but
the robot disobeys
shitty begins to rob jewelry perfumes
and every woman stuffed to impress sana
the police and the military even have to
team up in order to defeat chitty the
robot also steals an oil truck but the
police managed to corner him and finally
blow him up with a missile
not long after dr vasey arrives at the
crime scene only to confirm that the
parts are not chitties
the officer is confused as chitty is
robbing four places at the same time
the police in vasey head over to borah's
laboratory where they find borah dead
dr vasey checks the cctv footage finding
that chitty had formed an army of robots
that have exactly the same face as
chitty
bora forbid him as he wanted to sell the
robots to the terrorist
he threatened to kill sana if chidi
disobeyed but the clones took care of
him and chidi single-handedly executed
him after that shitty goes to art and
massacres everyone there he then alters
the art hq into his kingdom fully
guarded by his clones
chitty thinks that he has successfully
impressed sana but she feels uneasy and
states that it's impossible for her to
marry the robot
unfortunately shitty comes up with an
idea to create an artificial cell so
they both can have a baby robot sapiens
on the other side dr vasey disguises as
chitty and secretly infiltrates the
robot's kingdom
he eventually arrives at santa's room
where he deactivates a robot and reveals
his identity to her
he cuts himself to prove that he is a
human which makes sana relieved and hugs
her he tells sana his plan ordering him
to distract chitty for the next 24 hours
the plan begins and vasey calls his team
to shut down the entire city's
electricity
the robot doesn't care about the
incoming threat and chooses to have fun
with a woman
sana teases him for a very long time
until chitty is out of the battery
the robot becomes panicked as there is
no power source
just before his battery runs out he
finds a car and recharges using the car
battery
the clones also run to the street and
charge themselves
chitty returns to his mansion and
accidentally discovers human blood
the robot realizes that vasey was there
and questioned santa's loyalty
shitty immediately gathers his entire
army and orders them to spin their heads
because he is still human vasey is
easily spotted when chitty is about to
strike the bullet the military army
breaks in and shoots everyone in the
room
they use non-metallic weapons and
flashes to blind the robots
unfortunately shitty commands his clones
to form a shield and then launches a
counter-attack the robot gets out of the
building and fights the entire army
he uses his robot clones which can
transform into several weird shapes to
wipe out everyone
dr vasey manages to hack one of the
robots and successfully enters the robot
system he installs a virus that shuts
down the entire robot army but not for a
long time
chitty finds the source and immediately
applies a self-destruct command to the
robot
the robot army comes back online and
transforms themselves into an enormous
giant robot
dr vasey and sana try to flee in a van
while the giant is chasing after them
the robot effortlessly destroys every
military vehicle that tries to stop him
dr vasey manages to locate the real
chitty and shoots him with a transmitter
he then deactivates chitty's
electromagnetic power and then pulls the
robot with a huge magnet in the van
the scientist destroys the robot army
and manages to remove the red chip from
chitty's body
afterwards dr vasey is sentenced with
death penalty for all the damage caused
by his creation
chitty stands up and challenges the
decision
the robot provides evidence showing that
the deceased borah is actually the
mastermind of the destruction
finally the court concludes that dr
vasey is not guilty
however they ban the usage of humanoid
robots as they could turn against human
and have the opportunity of being
misused by terrorists
shitty is okay with that and decides to
dismantle himself
the robot apologizes to his creator and
dr vasey hugs him just before chitty
removes his head
the scene moves to 2030 when chitty's
head is kept in an ai museum
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching